let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
well good afternoon everybody
we have some news to get to there's been
a
couple happenings today and going to be
some happenings tonight that we're going
to talk about
we also have more killer cops
in the news i'll talk a little bit about
those but
the main story of the day is rudy got
raided
it's a nice little tickle of a song
there isn't it
rudy got raided rudy got raided
rudy rudy rudy got raided
so rudy giuliani
the former mayor of new york city
what a disgrace gets raided this morning
by
federal investigators so we'll go into
that a little bit now
oh pine and i got a couple uh of course
when i say a couple i mean handfuls of
tick tock videos about mr
grandpa farty mcshardy rudy
giuliani got plenty of those
videos so we're gonna play those and i
did a tick tock today about mr
grandpa farty mcsharty rudy giuliani
so we'll talk about that uh we're going
to talk about
mr joe biden the president of the united
states
your president he's going to address
the nation and a joint session of
congress
after a hundred days in office so i want
to give you a few
thoughts on that and why i think
that this address to
the joint session and the nation uh will
be historic
as far as visual is concerned and also
content
you know what he's going to say why he's
going to say what he's going to say
why it's important um and you know how
to make a
government sleepy again
you know make it boring let's make
politics boring
that's the whole point you know we don't
need the reality tv show 24
7. we don't anymore they try but we
don't
and then we also want to get to um
a couple cops killing
citizens of the united states human
beings one
was shot because they were confused
about a house phone being a
gun the other one was shot in a apparent
drug raid and somehow a bullet ended up
in the back of that
that person's head and then uh before
i came on here i i read and saw another
story about
someone out in california i forget his
name at this point because this is fresh
in my mind
but they pinned him to the ground for
more than five minutes
uh he became unconscious stopped
breathing they tried to revive him and
he died at the hospital so we'll talk
about those things today too
the first thing i want to talk about
which is outside of those subjects
um i've been texting a friend of mine
back and forth uh he he's a teacher
and uh there's there's a video out there
on the interwebs you know the ticky
talks the twitters the facebooks
of a new jersey i guess he's a principal
or vice principal or
somehow he's an administration in a
middle school in new jersey
uh him and his wife attended some sort
of outdoor event
and his wife i don't know if she was
creeping in the stall with this person
or what but
somehow she saw a transgender woman
taking a leak in a bathroom and she was
highly offended that a transgender woman
was going piss
she proceeded to come out and harass
these people and
not only that she was threatening one of
the employees at the
the foodery there the restaurant i'm not
sure exactly what it was i
i watched the video and then i read a
couple uh articles on it and i've been
texting back and forth with my friend
because anytime i see
one of these one of these teachers or
administration officials
uh do really stupid things on camera for
social media to see
it always uh it tickles my fancy so i
send it to him so we can have a
conversation about it because i'm not a
teacher he is
you know he works around teachers and
administration officials
so i kind of like to get a sense of how
they feel about some of these stories
but um apparently uh this this the
the principal's wife the karen in the
situation
was uh accosting not only the uh the
people with the transgender woman who
she was creeping on to see if she was
pissing or not i'm not sure
i don't you know i i've done i've done a
couple of
videos about this about how these people
are really
they're really weirdly concerned about
other people's genitalia in the bathroom
i have never ever ever went into a
bathroom stall to take a [ __ ]
and was completely concerned about the
person in the stall next to me what
their genitalia was i've ne
the thought has never entered my mind um
i just
i don't think about while i'm in the
bathroom
i just go in there and do my business
and get the [ __ ] out
um i these people are highly concerned
highly concerned
and then how you would even know like
how do you even know
that what someone are you he's peeking
to the stall door how does that even
[ __ ] work i'm not even sure
i mean when i go to the bathroom and i'd
go in there and do my [ __ ] and get the
hell out
um i'm not really paying much attention
to
what other people are doing in the
bathroom but apparently this woman was
and she noticed that this woman was
transgender
um so i don't know if she was peeing
standing up or
what i have no clue what the situation
was in the bathroom i just know the
video i saw
she's losing her [ __ ] on these people
outside so they're yelling back and
forth the employee gets involved the
employee says i'm going to go get my
manager you got to get the hell out of
here
um so the employee kind of walks off and
then this man from the distance kind of
walks in
that is the vice principal or the
principal of the school
and he has a cup of beer in his hand and
the karen his wife has a cup of beer in
her hand as well there
it's like a beer garden i guess and this
guy
walks up the principal walks up and he
flings his beer
on somebody now i i don't know exactly
who he threw it on it's very unclear
from the video
because you can't see in the video who
he threw it on but he threw it on
a person or people sitting at the table
with the transgender woman i'm guessing
and then they walk off and they're
yelling and screaming and he says i
thought yeah that's what i thought you
know you wouldn't do anything and see
blah blah blah
the main part of this story the funniest
part about this story
is of course this moron's probably gonna
lose his [ __ ] job
which he should because uh
number one you're you're you're hired by
the public you're a
public official you're a teacher um you
know
that's just how it works in your
administration of a middle school even
worse still to do this type of thing in
public in front of a camera you
[ __ ] bonehead so
he he apologizes and
when you read his apology it really
sounds like he's
really sorry that someone filmed him
doing it
he he's he's really sorry and he
apologizes
to you know people who would see the
person who filmed it and posted it on
social media
uh you know it's obvious that these
people are
you know homophobic transphobic
dumb [ __ ] and he he didn't think he was
being
filmed and he did what he did and then
once it posted and he
he got pushed back oh my god that's the
same thing in this video
uh of the ceo of a medical i guess it's
a medical electronic file company or
something in tennessee he accosted
uh some teenage boys that were wearing
dresses at a prom
and he it's really creepy the video he
looks really creepy and that's the same
[ __ ] and he lost his job
this week so uh keep it up boneheads
keep it up
keep getting on camera keep doing dumb
[ __ ] in front of a camera
so they can post it on social media and
you can lose your job so uh uh someone
else who's
more qualified than you obviously can
have that position and get paid that
salary
because you're a dumb [ __ ] so
let's move on to the next subject which
is this
uh biden's address tonight um
he's going to be addressed the joint uh
session of congress
for his first hundred days and his first
hundred days hasn't been
all bad it hasn't been all good either
uh you know he's he's still
dealing with the pandemic the ongoing
pandemic and trying to manage that
situation
i got he got to his goal
of 200 million shots before the 100 days
which is kind of significant because
when he first started back in january
they said a hundred million
shots uh was the goal everyone kind of
oh
hahaha 100 million that's all that's the
best you can do
and then they they upped it to 200.
there was a lot of republicans out there
that said oh yeah if he could get the
200 well then i'll praise him i'll clap
and i'll say yeah you did a great job
of course they're not but he he not only
broke the 100 million he got to the 200
million before the 100 days was up
um now that's not just joe biden that
that's
hundreds hundreds of thousands uh of
of workers to vaccinate these millions
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
people in this country
i'm one of them so i got my first
vaccine
moderna back in march and last week
friday i got my second modernist shot so
uh as far as the shots go i'm fully
vaccinated but i gotta wait the two-week
period before you're
considered fully inoculated
which brings to a to a second uh
thing about the the vaccine is the cdc
said yesterday if you're outside and
you're vaccinated you don't have to wear
mask so that's kind of cool
but i'm sure joe biden will talk a lot
a lot a lot a lot a lot a lot
about the pandemic tonight and the
progress that they've made
and the future progress that they would
like to make on the pandemic
specifically with the vaccine and the
cdc guidelines i'm sure
the other thing that i know that he's
going to
continue to talk about is this
infrastructure package that he wants to
put together
and uh he i think he's also going to
talk about the healing of
of the nation of the two sides this big
divide that we have in this country
which you know i we always have a divide
it's just
more clear now than ever so i think
he'll point that out
the most significant thing and the thing
i'm excited to see
visually with my eyes tonight is that
behind joe biden
behind him will sit
a female speaker of the house nancy
pelosi and a
female the first female vice president
of the united states
kamala harris which i think is a very
very very significant thing
to see two women sitting behind a
president
while he's giving a
joint session addressed to congress and
the nation
i think it's very very very significant
uh as significant as what he was what
he's gonna say now now we
know joe biden this is why
70 you know uh 82 million excuse me 82
million people
voted for jill biden is because it's
it's
he is predictable you know what he's
going to say you know what he's going to
do he's a decent human being
and i mean there's just you know he he's
not gonna
get outside the the presidential box
here
he's gonna be inside that presidential
box he's not gonna
get a flame thrower and create
flamethrower reality tv dumpster fire
like
the former guy blast [ __ ] which we're
going to talk about him here in a little
bit
in accordance to rudy
but i think he's going to be measured
it's going to be probably a
a very very very well-written speech
um joe biden tends to give a speech
pretty well sometimes he he flubs on
some of it so
i'm sure the media will be right there
to criticize as he
as he flubs a few parts of it or
uh [ __ ] up a few words or a few phrases
or
something and of course the right-wing
media oh
this socialist he's a socialist
he wants infrastructure he wants
infrastructure he's a socialist
we're gonna be a communist nation before
you know it
oh be scared cut hold your guns and your
bibles
run for the hills i mean that's that's
gonna be the natural
flow of the right-wing conservative part
of the country
that's what's that's just what's gonna
happen
they're gonna use fear that he's some
kind of commie socialist
so but i think i think it'll be very
predictable
i don't think he's gonna make a lot of
news tonight he may say a few things
that make news uh on his infrastructure
plan or the
or his plan to uh the ongoing pandemic
but i don't think he's gonna make a ton
a ton of news tonight i don't think
that's the purpose i think the purpose
is for him to be in front of a
microphone
so there's that now the next situation
before we get to
the rudy raid they raided rudy
rae rudy raided raided
ray rudy
the next situation is a couple of these
stories that we've seen
in the last week about more
black males and people of color being
killed by police officers
i don't know when this ridiculousness is
going to end
but the three stories that i have
uh seen being predominant in the news
the last few days
um one there was a announcement in the
courtroom
today for uh uh andrew brown
in north carolina the judge denied
the body cam to be released to the
public now the
apparently the media had filed for this
motion for the body cam to be released
to the public
i i guess i guess the family saw
part of the video but not all of the
video
and the judge denied that request in
north carolina now in other states the
reason why
uh like last week we saw the body cam
video of the teenage girl that was shot
and killed in
ohio because she had a knife in her hand
the reason why we saw it so quick is
because in ohio
the body cam footage of a police officer
is public record
so it can it it is legally it has to be
out in that space a lot
quicker and it's treated as public
record
now in north carolina it is not that way
apparently the law is different in each
state and north carolina
is different with the body cams now i
did watch
the judge uh give his decision publicly
uh he seemed like to make a lot of
excuses like
uh it would endanger people um it's not
really a public interest he you know he
went on and on and on he had a hundred
different reasons
now uh my thought is and and i i'm kind
of giving the judge leeway here
just a bit but my thought is is that if
this
by north carolina law if if the body cam
video is not public record
and it's not seen legally as public
record if it gets out into the public
i could possibly not knowing what's on
the video at this point
exactly it could possibly hinder any
kind of court case that would be brought
to court for
anyone who had or had anything to do
with shooting and killing
andrew brown apparently he was sh there
was uh he was
a gunshot wound to the back of the head
which is
not a good sign for these police
officers because apparently they went to
raid him it was a drug raid um i'm not
sure if he
if they suspected him of being a drug
dealer or drug buyer
i i don't know at this point i don't
think
anybody knows but he's a human [ __ ]
being who shouldn't be executed in the
back of the head
no matter what charges and this is this
is the ongoing
banter that we went through with with
george floyd that
he deserved to die or he was gonna die
because he was a drug addict
and if you got drugs in your system by
god that's your fault
you just yeah that warrants the death
sentence
and we're gonna do this one all over
again
then we had another situation uh where a
police officer
took a person home to his mother's house
i believe
and he got into an altercation with one
of his siblings
uh he called 9-1-1 uh the same officer
responded that dropped him off at the
house just
earlier when they came out when they
came he drawed this weapon
the person who got shot and killed the
citizen had a
cordless house phone in his hand the
officer
i guess assumed it was a gun i mean you
know a cordless house phone doesn't
really look like a gun but
i guess when it's in a black dude's hand
it does
we have to continue and continue and
continue to do this
and it is all for fear of guns
and people of color that's what this is
this white
gun culture you have to be afraid the
cops are afraid
people are afraid everyone's afraid fear
fear fear fear good guys bad guys [ __ ]
we continue and continue and continue to
do this
it's enough of this [ __ ] cut this [ __ ]
out
and really frankly we're headed down a
path where law enforcement aren't even
gonna have to
aren't even gonna be able to carry uh uh
semi-automatic weapons anymore
apparently shot him shot at him seven
times and i seen the video and i counted
seven now i'm not sure
i'm no you know ballistics expert but i
did
hear seven shots
he had a cordless house phone
cordless house phone
it's not like he shot at him once and
the guy
fired a bullet from the house phone at
him
he shot him seven times he pulled the
trigger
before he stopped not once did the self
or the cordless house phone go off not
once did he shoot him with the cordless
house phone
not once i wonder why
and he laid dead in the street now the
officer did it
did try to render him aid at that point
from the body cam footage
a lot of good that did when you unloaded
your [ __ ] clip into him
because he was holding a cordless house
phone
these officers are under-trained
they're trained to act on fear to fear
people to fear citizens they are not
here to protect and serve
they are here to fear us
especially people of color
so when people say defund the police
that's what the [ __ ] they mean
stop giving bad cops shitty cops
shitty departments money stop
if you can't get your [ __ ] together stop
you're killing citizens because he had
a [ __ ] cordless house phone
he didn't shoot him back with the
cordless house phone
he didn't shoot back he didn't fire back
there wasn't a gun fight that ensued
with the [ __ ] cordless house phone
there wasn't
enough of the [ __ ] excuses enough of
it oh well looked like a gun
well he was dangerous they were saying
on the on the 911
so your first instinct hearing the word
gun is to just shoot your gun
because you know you're a good guy with
a gun that other guy must be a bad guy
with a gun
you see the [ __ ] the sloper on
do you see it
it's all interconnected it's all
intertwined
and it needs to stop
then i read a story and i think i seen
the the part of the video i went and
looked up part of the video
someone of hispanic descent out in
california the man and i'm not sure what
he was doing i i haven't had a chance to
really
uh devour the story yet i just again i
read the story i went and
found the video i think it was on the
story
and uh watch the body cam footage again
here we are with body cam footage
as a man uh they were going to arrest
him it
took him a while to detain he was you
know not cooperating for being detained
and being arrested
and they put him on the ground in a
prone position
this is gonna get real familiar here
and they stayed on top of him for over
five minutes
[Music]
until he was unconscious was no longer
breathing
that's when they rolled him over and
rendered aid he later died at the
hospital
sounds familiar doesn't it we just had a
guy convicted
of murdering a person because he leaned
on his neck
for damn near 10 minutes
because they feared him because there
was fear
if you're afraid folks if you're afraid
of other people and your first thought
is to solve a problem with
a gun that's the wrong kind of [ __ ]
ideas
that we got we need to stop this gun
solves every problem you got
because it doesn't it only [ __ ] kills
people
that's it and i'm sure these officers
i'm sure these officers who leaned on
him were scared of him
they were afraid he was gonna hurt them
who knows if he had a gun
i'm sure there will be a right winger
somewhere sitting in front of a
microphone like this
saying that well who how could they tell
that he
that he didn't have a gun who knows
how how could statistically we tell that
he didn't have a gun well you couldn't
in this country
there's more goddamn guns than there are
people of course it's statistically
possible that every person
has a few firearms on them course it is
and you should be afraid
it's what's happening that's what's
happening
we're afraid and the only solution is a
gun rather you're a [ __ ]
good guy cop or the bad guy black dude
good guy bad guy [ __ ] stop it
it's enough
now i want to leave enough time to uh
get to the story of the day
that happened this morning
mr grandpa farty mcsharty
giuliani got raided by federal
investigators the fbi went to his
apartment apparently they were looking
for electronic devices
which if you're if you're
rudy giuliani rudolph giuliani
and and the feds are looking for your
electronic devices
you are [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] i mean just completely
[ __ ]
and i don't i don't know if they've got
a stockpile of depends diapers down at
mar-a-lago but i bet donald trump [ __ ]
himself about 20 times today
i i opined my my tick tock today
rather rather the former guy
how many times the home health aides had
to help him change his diaper because
i'm sure at every moment
every time he turned around there was
bad news
over this rudy raid so
but you know i've done a lot of tick
tocks on rudy rudy has had a
a a very interesting up and down the
last six months
with the election election fraud and
trying to defend trump and
the impeachment trial trying to get a
pardon i believe
and and i did a couple videos on that so
i want to share with you
i want to share with you all my great
pieces of tic toc
art and i'll explain why
why these things had significance of
today
you know finally here we are
so let's go to the first one the first
one was back right before
january 20th so so you gotta remember uh
donald trump was still the president of
the united states
uh he was on his way out um everyone was
like
what's gonna happen january 20th you
know all the q and on people were gonna
you know the something was gonna happen
and
donald trump was gonna you remember the
face-off thing where they're gonna
switch faces and donald trump swears joe
all kinds of crazy nonsense
so you gotta remember that that that's
kind of the context of this video
it was three days before january 20th
and what happened was if you remember
there was a story about all these people
showing up at the white house i think it
was jared
ivanka i believe mike pompeo was there
rudy giuliani was there and that was one
of the most significant videos is rudy
giuliani walking in with his big ass
briefcase
and when i was watching that piece of
footage i thought oh i wonder what the
[ __ ] he's got in that briefcase so i did
a little video about it so let me share
that with you more drama in the saga of
grandpa party mcshardy
let's talk giuliani was spotted walking
into the white house in an apparent
effort
to beg for a circle jerk with his orange
deity holding a briefcase which i can
only guess what the contents were some
old folded up pages with q anon
conspiracy theories on a worn out soon
to be expired new york state law license
don jr fingernail clippings caked and
booger sugar
pirated dvd of borat 2 not the whole
movie
just the part where he's playing with
his dick coffee stained napkin that has
all the people listed that he wants to
make sure they get pardoned
it's just got his [ __ ] name on it
that's it there's a folder with his
master plan on how he's gonna defend
trump
in the impeachment trial this is [ __ ]
christ we're still going to do this
election fraud [ __ ] after he's gone
thing he carries with him all the time
his cheeto dust stained sex swing
judy little piece of [ __ ] advice for
you january 20 is three days away
it's time to get a [ __ ] life [ __ ]
them
so there's there's there's actually a
lot to unpack about that 60 second video
uh one of the one of the craziest
one of the craziest things is
uh the napkin
so i i made this little joke that
that he had a coffee stained napkin with
the list of people he wanted pardon
and his name was the only one on the
napkin
which you know if you think about it why
the hell would you hand an afghan with
someone a list of people you want pardon
and only have your name
that's what that's why i thought it was
funny but now we see why
now we see why now it's becoming more
and more clear why rudy giuliani
would have would have been pardoned now
if there is still a chance and i don't
know what the chance is and i i
you know they keep talking about the the
possibility of secret pardons and
you know i i don't i don't know what
that even looks like um
that that that trump could have secretly
pardoned people and the only time that
these pardons would have been known if
if they do get uh indicted but i i would
imagine that he would have to actually
uh pardon them from charges that they
would indict them with
but neither here nor there uh
i'm sure i'm sure the the word pardon
came up
in that meeting in the context of what
happened today because apparently
uh it seems like the former attorney
general bill barr
had uh kind of held this warrant in his
pocket to make sure that rudy wasn't
wasn't raided and uh you know we we've
got a new attorney general now merrick
[ __ ] garland
and i think i think that's the cause of
this raid
is because merrick garland got sworn in
as attorney general he got
briefed uh they went over and uh they
made sure they had his approval to go
get uh mr rudy giuliani's
electronic devices now i wonder
i wonder uh what other things that they
that they got and that's that's that was
my video from today but
i do want to play another video about uh
grandpa farty mchardy
that i think has some very good
significance here
and i'll explain it after the video but
it has significance
it's it's a different court case it's
not a criminal court case it's a civil
case against him um i think you guys
know what i'm talking about
you know he ran around for months and
months and months uh
spreading falsehoods about dominion and
their voting systems
so uh let me play that video shorty
let's talk apple farty mcsharty rudy
giuliani gets served a set of papers
today dominion is suing his
[ __ ] ass for defamation no [ __ ]
sherlock out that he's being sued for is
two or three gazillion dollars i don't
know it's probably way more than trump
even owes him
so the four season total landscaping
saga continues jesus [ __ ] christ can
you imagine who's gonna defend him my
lynnwood sidney powell what the [ __ ]
strap on your seat belts america because
i'm sure it's all part of the plan
hey rudy a little [ __ ] piece of
advice for you you better tuck in your
shirt before you walk into court
that is not what they mean by release
the kraken [ __ ] them
you guys remember release the kraken
don't you holy [ __ ] that seems like
years ago uh but it was just just
yesterday that they were releasing the
kraken
and i'm i'm still waiting i'm still
waiting on the crack in here
you noticed there was a lot to unpack
about that one but i think the reason
why
the reason why this dominion case will
have such significance in
the case that they have now is because
uh
you know theoretically if you think
about it rudy giuliani's electronic
devices
uh not only probably have stuff about
ukraine and that is apparently the
federal and get
the federal investigators target for the
probe
is his dealings in ukraine uh but
i would imagine that those electronic
devices
also have stuff about the election on
them
i don't think he had a ukraine phone and
an election fraud phone
i mean maybe i'm wrong but rudy giuliani
if you've ever watched him handle a
phone or do social media
it doesn't seem like he knows how to run
a [ __ ] phone let alone two or three
of them
so i i do not see that rudy giuliani had
one phone for ukraine one phone for
election fraud
uh one phone for one phone for trump one
phone for
uh lynnwood and sydney powell and you
notice they showed up in that video
which are up the other two people that
are being sued by dominion
that's why i kind of threw them in that
video
so i think that's going to have a lot of
significance here
and the reason why is because not only
is he getting these people are getting
their pants suit off by dominion
i think a lot of this record finding is
going to uncover a lot of criminal
activity
uh in these civil suits and vice versa
vice versa vice versa
so mr giuliani is going to go through
some [ __ ]
as they say and then i i couldn't help
myself this morning
or yeah this morning when i seen uh mr
giuliani had been raided
rudy's been raided rudy's been raided
oh yeah rudy rudy rudy's been raided
when he was raided i couldn't help
myself i was about to go for my daily
walk and i was like
this motherfucker's getting another
video another farty mchardy video
here we come so i did a video today
and uh i wanted you know everyone was
posting on um
social media what things they would they
would take from his house and i had
already done a video on what was in his
briefcase so
i thought well maybe they would take
some of the stuff that was in his
briefcase
and then they would probably get some
extra things
so let me play that now then we'll talk
more about uh farting sharks more shitty
diapers
let's talk so today federal
investigators
raided grandpa farty mcsharty rudy
giuliani's house
damn i hope his electronic devices are
more secure than matt gatt's venmo jesus
[ __ ] christ
well it's about god damn time hey rudy
kaluti i got four awards for you
merrick [ __ ] garland [ __ ] makes you
wonder what else the fbi got in the raid
huh
his horde of disappearing reappearing
hair dye bootleg copy of borat two
cherished cheeto dust stained sex swing
personal collection of you
shitty trump diapers oh to use as a
security smell type blanket
looking at shitty diapers kinda makes
you curious on how many times the home
health aides have had to change the
former guy today
you're finally gonna get a [ __ ] life
in federal prison
[ __ ] them
[Laughter]
so obviously i'm i'm i'm making a guess
there that
not only is uh rudy giuliani gonna be
charged with a crime but
he might uh he might he
might see the inside of a of a federal
prison
so who knows what will become of this
but if you really think about it
if you really think about trump's
lawyers
and indictments and
lawyers that are tied to trump and
indictments
you look back and you say okay well
there was a guy
uh named paul manafort he was his
campaign manager but his right-hand man
who was
attorney uh gates was the one that uh
you know flipped on him um
and then we had michael cohen uh you
remember the raid on michael cohen when
this happened
i mean it was like earth-shattering [ __ ]
and the reason why is because donald
trump was still in
still in office so you know of course
they had to develop a reality show
plot line behind michael cohen getting
raided you know because they they ran
the white house
dumpster fire reality show so they had
to develop this plot line around it
which was all [ __ ] but uh michael
cohen
if you remember back just a little bit
it's been a lot of [ __ ]
you know a go but uh they raided him
and he squealed and he turned and he
pled guilty he actually went from pris
to prison for some time he was under
house arrest for some time
but he got sentenced uh uh to prison and
that was the last time that uh
that a quote unquote trump personal
attorney
was raided the outcome now
michael cohen apparently has still been
cooperating not only with
uh the sdny which is apparently where
this warrant came from that's
what the report is is showing that uh
the feds from the fdny
is the one that um that executed this
warrant
but that that that he's been cooperating
he's also been cooperating with
manhattan d.a
and that was part of his deal that he
had to cooperate and that's usually what
happens in the federal prosecution case
if you decide to take a plea deal and
you cooperate you have to continue to
cooperate
based on the evidence and the case that
they're trying to make on the deal they
gave you
so the next question would be is
when does rudy flip when does he flip
i mean let's see it's it's about 3
40 central time
here in the united states so that makes
it almost
five o'clock out on the east coast uh
he might he might be flipping by
midnight
would be would be my guess that he's
gonna go uh talk to people and some have
surmised that
he already has done uh uh
some talking to investigators possibly a
proffer
uh you know uh michael cohen i guess has
done several proffers
but uh that that rudy giuliani has done
a proper
and if he was seen to be lying that may
have what triggered this warrant to be
executed for to get these electronic
devices
because it's possible that he was
handing over documents to the feds and
they were not happy
with the amount of documents and the
holes in the documents meaning
that they assumed there was more
documents based on the information that
they already had
so now rather that's that's the reason
why they took the electronic
devices or not who knows but in my video
for the comedy aspect
i definitely wanted to surmise what
other things they take so i
i really i really do think that
the federal investigators would have
confiscated
his his prized used trump shitty diaper
collection for sure
and not only that as they would have
made sure
to put the cheeto dust stain sex swing
in the box
as well to make sure that was garnished
for
for evidence uh evidence for what i
don't know
but those two things the cheeto dust
stained sex swing and the trump
use shitty diapers brings up the next
thing that starts to turn in my mind
when i hear
ruby got raided rudy got raided
rudy got raided rudy got raided
that trump is down in mar-a-lago
losing his ever-loving [ __ ] mind
trying to figure out how the hell he's
gonna turn rudy giuliani into the
[ __ ] coffee boy i don't know that guy
i've never seen him in my goddamn life
i mean i take pictures with lots of
people
i don't know how the [ __ ] they're gonna
untangle this one i have no idea you
remember
the stormy daniels story is what
is what escalated the michael cohen raid
because there were what prosecutors
thought were illegal payments
from michael cohen to stormy daniels and
that
kind of undid michael cohen and caused
that
raid that's what happened
and it went from there and you remember
trump was on the
air force one and the reporters asked
him
ask and he was the president united
states they asked him
about the stormy daniels check that was
written
to stormy daniels from michael cohen
and trump's like i don't know hell you
have to talk to michael cohen [ __ ] i
don't i don't
who's michael cohen do i even know that
guy
uh i mean i've probably met him once or
tw twice i take a lot of picture with a
lot of people
but i mean he's his personal attorney
his fixer for years so
so that escalated into a raid
so i want to see i want to see what the
i i really wish we could get it on
camera but trump doesn't appear much on
camera anymore
and i i don't know if that's because uh
he doesn't want to be seen on camera
because the the
the depends are bulging or or what the
case is or maybe he's just too busy
golfing i don't know
i don't know he just can't he can't put
his makeup on
for a camera i have no idea but but
but i'm sure we'll get a statement soon
if
if we haven't already while i'm on the
air here about
if if trump knows rudy giuliani still
and how
well he's acquainted with him and how
much coffee he brought him at some point
maybe he's his diet coke [ __ ] i don't
know
but uh this is not good uh for rudy
giuliani number one but it this is this
is
really really [ __ ] horrible for trump
especially if they're probing the
ukraine thing
if you guys remember back the first time
he was impeached the first time
it was over ukraine that's what happened
it and it was over the dealings that
rudy giuliani
had in ukraine there was a whole goddamn
impeachment trial
the whole thing there was there was the
investigation in the house they
impeached him
i mean we had dozens of witnesses
dozens of witnesses uh uh actual
officials at the time and former
officials
that testified against trump and and and
his his cohorts in this in this scheme
to get ukraine to lie about a case
against biden because
trump and his team were terrified that
biden would win which they were correct
i mean you know a broken clock's right
twice a day
but they were terrified that biden would
be the nominee and and
they they were rightfully to be
terrified because
i i i would say that they thought that
trump did not have any chance in hell of
beating a decent human being
i think that's probably the case and and
joe biden has
been way more teflon than donald trump
could ever dream of
and the reason why is because there's
just not much to stick to joe biden
it's not much i mean
it's hard i mean jesus christ
this morning they were yapping about
hunter biden's laptop again
i mean joe biden's gonna give an address
to the nation about what he's done in
the last hundred days and what he's
gonna do in the next hundred
and the right wing is concerned about
hunter biden's laptop still
and i guess maybe maybe maybe they could
surmise that
that's why the feds went to rudy
giuliani's house to look for hunter
biden's laptop
as if as if rudy giuliani was hiding
hunter biden's laptop
from federal investigators that might
investigate and
indict hunter biden i don't understand
how you even get that logic because it's
that's gonna come that's gonna be part
of this [ __ ] spin here
is that they went to rudy giuliani's
house to find hunter biden's laptop so
they could prosecute him
as if as if rudy giuliani was somehow
the deep state
hiding hiding hunter biden's laptop
from the fed so that they couldn't
indict hunter biden
yeah i mean i they don't even know what
to believe anymore if that's going to be
their little narrative
but they were so concerned about hunter
binding's laptop this morning
[ __ ] concerned about it hunter biden
has not got a fingernail on government
trump hired his entire family and
and his family's family's family to be
part of government because no one else
would work for him frankly
no one in the right mind wanted to be
anywhere near that [ __ ]
now we know why but his i mean his his
kid his son-in-law were in the white
house
and he was taking advice from his son
his personal lawyers and his personal
friends all around him
giving him advice and we're worried
about hunter biden
get the [ __ ] get the actual [ __ ] out of
here
get the [ __ ] out of here i'll tell you
what i'll tell you what trump and his
supporters need to be worried about
these trump humping cubanon maga people
here's what you need to be worried about
if you're listening out there
i'll tell you all this narrative about
how
great americans and how much they love
the country
and all this [ __ ] it's about to all
come crashing down on you people
all of it the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] and
caboodle
because i'll tell you one thing that i
think about rudy giuliani that'll be
more true
than anything i've ever heard is that
him and trump
him and trump continued continue to have
communications on electronic devices
and they didn't know a [ __ ] thing
about how they worked
not a [ __ ] thing there's evidence we
have
public evidence of that number one when
when trump called georgia he was being
recorded
dummy number two during the insurrection
on january 6
rudy giuliani was trying to call tommy
tuberville
the new senator from alabama and he
mistakenly called mike lee
you get your contacts [ __ ] up in your
phone give me a [ __ ] break
no they don't know how to run these
[ __ ] things
that's what you're gonna find out and
the best part is
is that all that evidence is gonna be
saved on those electronic devices
and these boneheads have no clue and
rudy giuliani
what are you supposed to do when trump
won in 16 wasn't he supposed to be
the [ __ ] the computer security person
for the nation or some [ __ ]
this guy can't even [ __ ] call the
right person from his iphone are you
kidding me
oh for [ __ ] sake
so i'm sure that donald trump is is
absolutely uh concerned today but not
only uh
uh donald trump
the former gay the former president but
also his children
uh because i think they had a lot of
hand in everything
that he did especially in communication
with rudy giuliani
donald trump jr ivanka jared
i think they communicated heavily with
rudy giuliani i think they seen rudy
giuliani as a way to influence the
president sometimes
uh to get him to back down if as you
remember
go back and remember
there was a meeting in the white house
with the kraken sydney powell
and rudy giuliani was the voice of
reason
mike flynn and sydney powell went to the
white house to meet with the president
it was hours and hours and hours of this
meeting
and rudy giuliani was the voice of
reason here to not
you know they wanted him to execute the
insurrection act or some [ __ ] or i don't
know
just [ __ ] way out there bone-headed
[ __ ]
the same on the same level as mike pence
had the power to overturn the election
type [ __ ]
his boneheadedness q anon conspiracy
theory
[ __ ] flat earth maga trump humping
[ __ ]
full stop [ __ ]
all the way up to your neck and [ __ ]
so i would imagine
that trump world trump his allies his
family rudy giuliani anyone anyone tied
to rudy giuliani is [ __ ]
terrified because mike michael cohen
has flipped and is i mean he's still
cooperating
we have the les partes the the the uh
the ukrainian associate
of rudy giuliani who cooperated and is
cooperating still i'm assuming
and many others that i'm sure are
yelling and screaming at the top of
their lungs
and it won't be long rudy it won't be
long
it won't be long until rudy giuliani is
on the list of people who flipped on
donald trump
it will happen it will happen
and i'm sure you know you got these uh
uh city pals and lynn woods
roger stones uh these real crackpots out
there
that are also kind of tied to rudy
giuliani and
and they they were you know they're kind
of tied in this interweb with trump
um you know that's they did that that's
also a little
a little scared of probably the
communication that they had with rudy
because i'm sure i'm sure these
boneheads trusted
trusted the communication electronic
communication with rudy it would say
text
email anything they wanted whenever they
wanted
and i'm sure that is exactly why federal
prosecutors went to gain
to get access to his electronic devices
so hopefully in the months to come we
will see more on this rudy giuliani
story and i'll get to do another farty
mcshardy video
i'm super excited i i always the the
farty mcsharty tic tacs uh uh walking
[ __ ] rants uh the the farty make
shardy ones are always
always always a favorite of mine i got
super excited
this morning uh when they raided him
because i knew
i knew that it wasn't raining outside it
was supposed to but it wasn't raining
i knew i was gonna get to do another
cherished grandpa farty mcjarty
video today so i was super excited about
that and i can't wait for the other ones
to come
and i'm glad you guys joined us on the
podcast today we have a few minutes left
so if you all if you've gotten me all
the way to the end here i know
i know that you love listening to the
app into a microphone if you've listened
this long
so i want to mention a few things about
supporting the podcast
so we can keep this going i i enjoy
doing this every wednesday at three
o'clock
central four o'clock eastern every
single wednesday we're live on youtube
we're live on twitter
and if you miss it it's okay we got that
youtube channel you go watch it
but if you want to support the podcast
more than just watching it
great we have a way you can do it you go
to thetonymichaels.com you can either
get some cool hats
you see me always wearing the [ __ ]
hats or you can go to the merch store
we've got stickers
[ __ ] stickers we've got coffee bugs
there's pillows there's t-shirts
all kinds of great stuff so all that
would go to the podcast
of helping us keep it here and keeping
it published
and keep making the podcast keep doing
it
because i do appreciate all you guys uh
giving it
uh so while i'm sitting here i see some
comments coming in and i want to give a
shout out
brandy says your pro your podcast gives
me life
and brandy i really appreciate that i
hope you keep listening
um and we'll keep talking i'm going to
keep talking i'm not going to stop
i won't stop and i'm excited today
because
that song is stuck in my head rudy got
rated
rudy got rated rudy rudy
rudy got raided rudy got raided
this usually isn't a music show it
usually isn't a singing show but today
today is a great day to sing
today is a great day to sing so
brandi says she's getting a hat well
we've got black and white hats brandy
uh there's excuse me gray and black geez
i don't even know
there's gray and there's black so go to
thetonymichaels.com they're at the very
top i believe
the [ __ ] hats and i'm gonna try i'm
gonna try to get some trucker hats as
opposed to the fitted hats
the fitted hats are really nice they're
flex fit hats
um they're embroidered um they're
they're a really nice
comfy fitting hat that's why i wear them
um
so it's a really but it's kind of an it
is more expensive
hat so we're gonna try to get some more
affordable trucker hats but the other
thing i wanna do
with these hats with these [ __ ] hats
is i wanna change some colors
because i know some people like more
colors um so maybe we'll do some
different colors on the trucker hats
so that way you can have a uh that that
way that way
you can have a selection if you want to
a certain color like a
red white and blue or something like
that so maybe we'll do some of that but
i you know the the nice part about color
and [ __ ] them on the merch store
we've got sweatpants there is pink
shirts there's women's shirts
unisex shirts um there's all kinds of
stuff over there so go look over there
and if you like a coffee mug
the coffee tastes way better in a
[ __ ] mug
than just a regular mug tastes way
better in that mug
so i appreciate you guys joining me
today and and come back next week
come back next week wednesday three
o'clock we're live
i do this show live people
we're live three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern on youtube
i also stream on twitter
at the same time and if you don't catch
it live
or you only catch part of it that's okay
it's recorded it goes up on the youtube
channel you can re-watch it
and i always cut clips to put them on
twitter and tick-tock
uh you guys seem to like the the tick
tocks the tick tocks the
the [ __ ] rants the walking that's
probably
uh everyone loves those videos
at the most and then i have the series
that i've been doing
uh have you ever noticed have you ever
noticed
so i like that one because they're short
sweet they're to the point
i try to make a good point really quick
uh when i see hypocrisy
and it works out great so thanks for
joining me today
i can't wait for next week hopefully
we'll have
more on what is going to happen with
these police
shootings and these police killing
citizens
as as in andrew brown and some of these
other cases that we talked about today
the other thing that we will see between
now and the next podcast is joe biden's
address tonight
so we'll see maybe next week there'll be
some significant news that he makes and
we'll talk about it
i doubt it i don't think joe biden's
gonna make a lot of news tonight
it's gonna be [ __ ] we already know uh
from jinsaki that she's already said in
the press briefing room because she's
like
master master press secretary
she [ __ ] kicks ass
john wayne toilet paper [ __ ]
rough tough and don't take [ __ ] off
nobody is what she is fantastic press
secretary
and the reason why the reason why that
is so important is because
that's why it's so important is because
she is supposed to make some of the news
in the press room
not necessarily joe biden making a lot
of news
on the stage in front of the entire
nation
he's gonna make some news but it's it's
not gonna be like
earth-shattering stuff it's gonna be
small
it's gonna make a difference but it's
gonna be small incremental stuff you'll
see that
and we'll talk about it next week maybe
maybe i'll make a point
to give you my evaluation next week for
a few minutes
of joe biden's speech tonight
and then maybe just maybe next week
we'll have some more rudy giuliani news
i doubt it
but maybe we will maybe we'll have some
leaks
somewhere but until then until next week
[ __ ] up you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them